as a simple demographic matter we see
that opposition to pot legalization is
stronger the older you are we're
definitely going to live to see it
happen prop 19 literally lost in that it
did not win enough vote from the people
of California to legalize adult
possession and growth in marijuana the
proponents of it have made a very
convincing case at on a certain level
prop 19 did win a victory for the larger
cause of drug legalization that's going
to pan out more in the future it's the
largest percentage for a full adult
legalization initiative or proposal that
we've ever seen its popularity among the
young is overwhelming people under 25
over sixty percent and they knew this to
begin with it was going to become an
issue of whether they could get those
young voters to go to the polls in
numbers larger than normal and they
failed at that 19 is a little bit of as
recently as two months ago it was
polling with enough support that I and
others actually believed it might win
they successful although outspent no 119
campaign stressed the sort of general
fear that a lot of people have about
marijuana users and the dumb things they
might do there were elements in the
proposal that concerned employers rights
to punish or discipline people who are
on marijuana those things probably
didn't need to be there I should say
that relations between employers and
employees about pot or anything else
should not be legislated people had
fears which I think were groundless that
somehow there would be so much more pot
use that the danger of drugged driving
would increase now of course we already
know that lots and lots and lots of
people in California are already smoking
marijuana neither in California nor any
other state that has medically legal pot
have we seen any increase in the problem
of drugged driving but that was sort of
a classic a reefer madness fear that i
think was convincing especially to the
older voters who overwhelmed the younger
voters and actually coming out to the
polls
so California today like California
yesterday is a state where you can
possess and smoke marijuana if you have
a recommendation from a medical doctor
saying you're able to we've had that
system in place since the prop 215 in
1996 it is not a state unfortunately
where any adult could possess up to an
ounce or grow up to five by five feet on
their own property which is what
proposition 19 would have given us
another thing that actually happened
almost certainly as a political result
of 19 being on the ballot which is also
a great victory for drug law reform
Senate bill 14 49 which governor
schwarzenegger signed into law last
month almost certainly is an attempt to
blunt support for 19 which he like every
other member of California's political
class was a violently opposed to that
reduces the punishment for possession of
lesson and outs for an adult to what's
called a mere infraction the legal
equivalent of a traffic or parking
ticket individual users in California
are reasonably free there at least free
of the fear of arrest however that does
not mean that the state of California is
not still spending far too many of its
police resources and wasting its
citizens time enforcing even this
infraction is probably going to become a
sort of revenue generator almost in the
same way that traffic tickets are which
means one of the great benefits of 19
that we're not seeing is that it would
have eliminated this on its face excuse
for police to harass people the notion
that if they smell pot or think they
detect Todd on you they can stop you and
searching from a civil rights
perspective even if you don't care about
marijuana particularly if you care about
the civil rights of young minorities to
take that weapon out of polices hands
would have been one of the great
advantages of 19 which is why groups
like the California and double ACP the
black Police Officers Association the
Latino Police Officers Association and
lulac all were part of the yes on 19
coalition
the last time a western state had a
chance to vote on something equivalent
with full adult legalization was Nevada
in 2006 and only got forty four percent
California we managed to get forty-six
percent and in sheer numbers of voter
it's an enormously larger number which
is significant the national level a lot
of these western states Colorado Nevada
California that have been the leaders on
the medical issue you can frequently
find polled support for adult
legalization over fifty percent it
didn't pan out that way in the voting
yesterday but those demographics and the
demographics of the fact that opponents
of Derby legalization are aging and
dying I think make it inevitable whether
it's in four years or six years another
thing that encourages me is the forces
behind these reforms have not lost hard
at all they're still very dedicated to
these cause they have a fair amount of
money behind them though once again
money definitely does not win victories
and elections yes on 19 outspent no 119
at least 8 21 and still lost as an
educational matter that kind of money
means more opportunities to get a
message of sense and logic out to more
people and I and the supporters of 19
were not discouraged too much by what
happened was very close and there's
every reason to think that the more we
give voters a chance to mull over these
things to think about them in
environment free of classic reefer
madness that they will come around